[Music]
foreign
to start studying biostatistics after a
long accumulation of data on empirical
evidences from clinical trials from a
provisional studies from other field
research we have done finally I think we
have all the data to make breakthrough
so this is a perfect timing and very
interestingly if you open a public house
or medical journal from 10 years ago and
compared to a journal published let's
say this month you will clearly see this
increase in data based research so
public health and medical research
nowadays utilize more and more on data
also biostatistics is the only field
that can combine the parallel
mathematics statistics computer science
and health genetics
the goal of that bio style Charter
resource is to provide analytic support
to all Cancer Center projects and
investigators we have been involved in
designing studies monitoring studies
analyzing data and finally presenting
our findings we have a support in skin
cancer to analyze data collected here
and also from other news videos from our
collaborators to really understand this
biological process how you'll be
interact with certain genes and how that
interactions that combined effects can
increase skin cancer risk can lead to
fast prognosis and finally bad response
to cancer treatment
foreign
[Music]
ERS have made significant contributions
to copy modeling our research has had a
direct impact on how the state deal with
coveted and to the best of my knowledge
has had a direct impact on how policy
was made at a national level and also we
have a very strong implementation
Science Center it's one thing to design
a perfect study on paper but it's
totally a different story how to
actually Implement that and how to
really deal with real problems you will
encounter in the real world our
researchers have been working on how to
better design conduct and analyze
clinical trials and observational
studies in United States and also
worldwide also we have been conducting
omics and imaging research just to try
to better and understand cancer
cardiovascular disease or mental
disorders and the biomarkers of my
colleagues identified have been direct
Target for pharmaceutical companies so
some have entered early and middle stage
clinical trials and those findings can
have a running their impact on how we
treat those complex diseases in the near
future
[Music]